in our series three meals we travel to
different states to break bread with
voters in here what's on their minds
what are they thinking so this month we
went to the Iowa State Fair a lot of
people there which wrapped up over the
weekend it attracted more than a million
people than the state's capital Des
Moines including more than a few
presidential candidates political
correspondent ed O'Keefe has been going
to the fair for more than a decade you
just heard him wait raving about the
pork chops pork chop sandwich he joins
us now from Sioux City Iowa I always
wanted one of those edie what you learn
at the fair at this time okay we learn
so much including you shouldn't have
more than one pork chop a day but we'll
get to that later
looks boaters in this in this rural
state have the first crack at deciding
who might take on President Trump next
year so we talked to fair goers about a
wide range of issues from health care to
the environment to gun control and found
out that even some supporters of the
president are open to a change day at
the fair begins early as thousands who
camp out overnight go in search of
breakfast
we visited Hardenbrook when we met
Democrats Dennis and Janet Hampton
who've been coming to the fair since
they got married half a century ago I
get a lot of friends in a group of Iike
Japan they're saying the same thing we
gotta work together now so whoever
Democrats nominated it's got to be
somebody who's willing to work with
Republicans both Hamptons are concerned
about climate change and they're turned
off by the president's approach to
immigration we're all immigrants your
state has a reputation as being nice you
see all this fighting that goes on in
Washington communication don't say most
eating if the fair happens on the go
this is gonna be good with more than 80
food items available on a stick but the
fair is also a display of Iowa's farming
and one of the most popular sights is
the famous butter camp
attracting tens of thousands of people
each day about 85 percent of Iowa's land
is used for agriculture it exports about
10 billion dollars in output each year
but that's been on the decline because
of the fight over trade and tariffs for
lunch we visited the rib Shak car we
caught up with Georgia gent a farmer
from Wellman and her friend Jane
Ackerman
one thing we I've heard said every time
the president sends out one of those
tweets about China or trade a farmer is
potentially losing thousands if not
hundreds of thousands of dollars yeah
tens of thousands of dollars can be lost
if you're looking out for the country if
you're looking out for the family
we don't need to have controversy like
that
we market our dos expects us and small
business a big time
yeah if they don't have a good year
they're not gonna be buying you know
$10,000 more in the spring Ackerman and
her family sell golf carts and lawn
mowers in Eastern Iowa and while
business is good they're feeling the
impact of the president's policies I
know right now we're having huge
problems getting parts to fix mowers we
can't fix it because we can't get part
and that's hard Ghent a Democrat likes
former Vice President Joe Biden in
Massachusetts senator Elizabeth Warren
but she's keeping an open mind before
the election I want to see everybody
that I've interested in I am a
registered ok and I'm just ready for
change and he hasn't delivered
necessarily I don't amid the throngs of
people who come to this Fair every year
about two dozen people who want to be
President were you here for any of the
presidential candidates you see any of
them
are you participating in the caucus in
February have you picked a candidate yet
from one food stand we followed max
Bert's sauce and his girlfriend Brett
deep Young Democrats who support
Medicare for all
so you both have health care work and
you're willing to part ways with that
absolutely through my job I still have a
2,000 dollar deductible I'd rather pay
some in taxes up front and know that I
can go to the doctor whenever I feel
like I need to Bert Jones recently moved
to Des Moines from Dayton Ohio and was
shook by the recent mass shooting there
that was 15 minutes away from my house
there's even a level of I won't lie
waking up today and going like okay
we're going to the fair later did
something could happen here yeah it's
really terrifying I'm fairly firmly
pro-gun control at the end of the day I
think we gotta try something though
because doing nothing has just made it
worse and worse and worse
fun at the fair continues well after
dark with rides live music and beer
we grabbed a drink at this craft beer
tent where we met a voter President
Trump will need to keep if he hopes to
win Iowa November conservative Bill
Stanislaw and one voter the president
may need to win back soybean farmer Amy
stem who says she supports the
administration's tariff strategy boy do
I love coming to Iowa and not only
important to come here because it's an
early primary state but because it's
also a swing state in the general
election Barack Obama won here in 2008
and 2012 before of course president
Trump defeated Hillary Clinton here in
2016 so it's an enticing target for
whoever the Democratic nominee might be
it has just six electoral votes but in a
close election those six could tip the
scales all right well done I think your
trusty anchor team wants to take a field
trip there I want to take a field trip
at I saw very few people of color I
think I saw a black guy in the
background you and I need to go to the
fair together well Gail I will tell you
this we couldn't walk 50 yards through
that fair without people saying they
watch this every morning if the four of
us showed up we get mobbed oh I like
those 80 food items on the stick did you
try it only about three of them Anthony
well many elections doesn't cover you
bacon I am gay we appreciate it we'll be
there soon I hope